why are unmade decisions so heavy at
least for me it's because I have this
hamster wheel on the my back of my mind
where I keep playing out different
scenarios because I'm I'm a big frame
guy so I'm like maybe I just need to be
thinking about this or maybe if I zoom
all the way out the Earth doesn't exist
so maybe this doesn't matter you know I
reframe all those things but usually
it's just because I'm afraid of
something and then that's why I'm not
making the decisions and it's usually
not even a thing that I'm afraid of it's
one person's judgment I'm afraid of and
then when I name the person then it
becomes real instead of being this
amorphous like people Society judgment
it's like Tom like do I really care what
Tom thinks I guess so it seems like I'm
not making this big change in my life
because of Tom looks like Tom's more in
control of my life than I am